So last time we spoke about the collapse of the Roman empire and I didn't quite
definitively answered the question.
Uh,
external force,
internal collapse.
Uh,
there are other possible explanations that eminent historian and the barbarians
says that the Roman Empire committed suicide by accident.
Uh,
that essentially it was just a political problem.
The wrong people became emperors,
some bad things happened and one day,
oh,
there it was,
it was gone.
Uh,
sure.
I buy that.
I like longterm causes more.
But it is important to emphasize that a lot of this is contingency and not
inevitability.
Historians generally tend to make things look as if they had to happen as if
there are sort of longterm things playing out inevitably.
Um,
and the longer or the farther away the historian is from the period that he or
she is studying,
the greater that tendency because the look back is longer.
So in talking about both the empire and the barbarians,
I want to at least remind you that events could have gone other ways.
Uh,
there are lots of longterm tendencies,
but uh,
we're talking about a series of,
of factors that are both immediate and long term.
This is relevant to talking about the barbarians and who they are,
which is a more of a mystery than it might seem.
Who they are as in what does it mean to say that someone is a physic off?
How much have I described what that means?
And despite the business about plunder,
that's not actually the only thing they were after.
As we have tried to emphasize they liked the Roman empire.
Uh,
they wanted to share in its advantages not to destroy it.
We've emphasized accommodation rather than conquest.
We've said that this is the end of a world,
not the end of the world.
It is the end of a certain civilization perhaps or maybe transformation of that
civilization.
But it's not the end of civilization.
They're not invaders from outer space.
Where do they come from?
Who are they are,
who are they?
What are these aspects of accommodation?
That's partly what we want to talk about today in discussing the barbarian
kingdoms after the collapse of Rome.
So for 76 to five 30,
what happens in five 30 is that the eastern Roman Empire embarks on a recon
quest of the west under the emperor Justinian.
And that will be the subject of our discussion a week from today.
Any questions in the meanwhile?
Okay.
Notice that in the Burgundian code,
the authors of the code,
the Burgundians called themselves barbarians,
they distinguished between barbarians and Romans.
Um,
even though they use the word it's deceptive to think of barbarians or tribes or
Germans as if these were absolute well defined terms that corresponded to an
absolute well defined set of realities.
What do we know about these people before they enter the empire?
Uh,
we know something from archeology,
but as they moved around,
as I said,
they're not nomadic.
They have settlements,
but they're not very urban settlements.
They have grave sites.
People who have grave sites with a lot of graves are not moving around a lot.
So that's one indication.
And the grave sites sometimes have stuffing,
uh,
things buried with them.
Uh,
and among other things,
they show that they had trade with the Roman Empire because they've got Roman
artifacts in them.
Well,
okay.
Uh,
but we actually don't find out that much about them.
the main written source for pre,
uh,
invasion,
let's call them Germanic tribes delicately,
is Tacitus the Roman historian,
better known or best known for his very pessimistic annals of the history of the
Roman Empire,
but also the author of a brief work called Germani.
Yeah.
About the German tribes
for Tacitus,
the Germans.
That is the people's living beyond the Rhine frontier are both childlike and
Novo
there,
like
from the Roman point of view,
these barbarians are intent on invading the empire and enjoying its riches.
Hence the defensive kinds of frontiers.
We've talked about the Rhine or in Britain,
uh,
Hadrian's wall,
which you can still see a in the north of England,
not that far from the Scottish border that to guard,
not against Germans,
but Celts picked and Scott's in particular
Tacitus portrays the Germans as kind of warlike
round the year 100 is his description,
but he never visited
Kermani.
Yeah.
And if you'd asked him,
well,
if you're going to write about them,
shouldn't you do some field work?
He'd have looked at you as if you were crazy.
Go the Air Mi ma.
Uh,
you gotta be kidding.
The reason he wrote the work was probably not an anthropological description of
the Germans,
but as a way of berating the Romans,
if you describe people who are virtuous but primitive,
you can use that to castigate your own people.
Rousseau's noble savage where the American Indians are used to attack supposedly
civilized societies is an example.
Or,
um,
descriptions of the south seas.
Some of Herman Melville's earlier works or Robert Louis Stevenson or Gauguin's
paintings contrast a beautiful natural,
simple world,
far superior to the,
uh,
fatiguing rat race of what passes for civilization.
So Tacitus,
as Germans are warlike concerned with personal bravery and honor.
They have close family ties
there.
Heterosexuals,
uh,
they treat their women well.
All of these are supposed to contrast with what Tacitus,
who's a bit of a scold.
Tacitus sees as Roman decadents.
The Romans are given to prostitution,
none of that in the German realms.
The Romans are given to same sex
love.
Oh No,
no.
The Germans know that that is really evil.
Uh,
they don't practice divorce according to Tacitus.
Now,
this is not,
you know,
this is a moralistic rather than an ethnographic treatise.
He does condemn them for certain vices.
The vices typically ascribed to so called primitive peoples by the civilized.
They're lazy,
they tend to get drunk,
they quarrel,
they gamble.
Okay.
In several respects,
Tacitus,
however,
describes things that are true of later German practices,
visible in the Burgundian code,
for example,
and that he does not make up for any particular moralistic purpose.
Two of these things are the coma taught to us.
Mccomber Tartus is the important men surrounding the leader,
his entourage.
But his military entourage is armed men.
Not just bodyguards,
but members of a gang,
I guess would be the closest similar people who are loyal to their superior,
but who are,
have a certain amount of autonomy.
They're not just sort of paid.
Uh,
as I said,
body guards,
they are his
followers.
We can say an anachronistic word would be vassals anachronistic because it's not
used at this time.
His military followers.
Armed military followers.
The Comma Tatas Tacitus describes the feud
feud between clans feuds are generally characteristic of society's without a
strong central government and with fairly generous definitions of kinship.
Generous definition of kinship means you know who your second cousin is,
maybe your third cousin,
maybe your third cousin twice removed.
And that cousin is going to consider your interests to be his or her interests
as well.
You might expect your children or parents to support you,
but you probably don't expect your great uncles or cousins,
second cousins to do much for you.
So in terms of vengeance,
which is also a protection,
in other words,
I am protected by the fact that if somebody kills me,
uh,
my clan will take vengeance on their clan in terms of protection and vengeance.
Uh,
extended kinship is related to a feud and to keeping order in a society that
doesn't have a very powerful central government.
One way of avoiding feuds that kill too many people is compensation.
And this compensation is mentioned by Tacitus and is what appears in the
Burgundian Code.
And elsewhere as very gelled,
very guild is the money paid in compensation for hurting or killing someone.
I kill your brother and we have a drunken brawl.
Uh,
I don't like the way he describes my mother.
and I killed him.
I'm sorry,
but uh,
but um,
that's just the way things go.
What are you going to do about it?
Are you going to kill me?
Are you going to kill a cousin of mine or maybe you'll accept compensation based
on say what kind of guy he was.
Was he a silver Smith,
in which case I to have to pay a huge amount of money.
Uh,
um,
or was he just some guy,
some random god,
random Burgundian or free Burgundian or free,
formerly slave.
Uh,
all of these are terrorists.
They're sliding scales of compensation.
Tacitus mentions this,
so we're looking at the Burgundian code and there are other barbarian law codes
for clues as to how this society function.
But of course it's a society that's already in the Roman Empire.
It looks like before they entered the empire,
they lived in little villages.
They cultivated grain,
but they were more cattle raisers.
They're skilled at iron working.
They also supplemented their income by a spot of rating and a warfare.
A opportunistic warfare.
Ties of kinship are very important.
When we're talking about a clan and extended kinship group,
we're talking about maybe 50 households.
Okay,
and we'll see this again.
We'll see this with the better ones in the desert,
for example,
within the clan,
you're not supposed to feud,
not supposed to.
Above the clan level is some kind of confederation for tribe,
and this is where things get kind of difficult because we don't really know how
one clan considered another clan to be part of something larger.
That is,
we know that the Romans called the people who defeated them at Adrian Opal,
the Visigoths,
oh my gosh,
here I am Adrian Notebook.
The Visigoths are winning.
What am I going to do?
But who are the Visigoths?
One theory is that they're just groups of people who come together in contact
with the Roman empire,
in part because the Roman empire calls them something,
gives them a name,
and they develop what's called fictive kinship from a common ancestor.
They invent the notion that they all come from one place and one ancestor.
This process of sort of fictitious ethnic invention is called ethno.
Genesis Ethno Genesis means the birth of an ethnicity
rather than some kind of biological fact that you could confirm with DNA.
You know,
our Eg all Visigoths have some sort of biological thing in common.
These people are not really related,
but they invent a common ancestor.
And this question of who forms a real group,
uh,
remains,
both important as a real thing.
For example,
American Indian tribes,
there are some who is claims to existence are indisputable.
They have treaties with the United States,
they've had reservations for many years,
but now with the,
um,
inducements for tribes,
the tax free status,
the ability to have casinos and things like that,
there are petitions for tribes to be recognized as such.
And here the question of ethnicity,
ethnic identification becomes extremely important.
A more sinister and much more widespread modern aspect of ethno genesis is
precisely the use of the Germanic barbarians as the origins of the Germans.
It's no accident that,
uh,
in the late 19th and early 20th century culminating but not limited to the
Nazis,
the idea of the Germans as a racial group,
as a group with a common Arion with a y ancestry
as manly and as
pure in the sense that tacit does portrays them becomes a polemical idea,
a fighting idea,
uninvented idea of great force.
Just because something is false,
it does not necessarily lack of historical importance.
So the idea of the f no genesis of the invention of a group called the
Visigoths,
uh,
is,
one way of approaching who they are.
On the other hand,
there's not a whole lot of evidence that they're doing this.
There's not a whole lot of evidence that they are developing this notion of a
common ancestor.
Much of the evidence or seeming evidence for that is Rome.
A lot of this f no genesis comes from contact with the Romans.
Certainly people who come in contact with those who are more civilized than they
are.
And by civilized,
I mean people's who have writing,
who live in cities,
who have extensive trade and administration.
Uh,
the so called barbarian peoples are going to want to define themselves against
the Romans.
Hence among other things,
many of these invaders are Arion with an eye.
They use religious difference as part of their identity.
So
they have come into the empire and as we said last time,
they come into the empire first as allied troops,
as refugees,
as Federal Rati Fed Herati.
That is to say a armies of the Roman empire.
They are supported by a system with the bland name of hospitality,
hospitality,
meaning that they're settled on the land of Roman,
uh,
of Romans.
And they share in the revenue of that land.
Okay?
That's how the Romans pave them.
They don't pay them cash,
they don't pay them and plunder,
they paid them in a portion of the tax revenue.
So you owe a reasonably powerful but not quite powerful enough.
Senator in Burgundy,
you settle some friendly Burgundian troops on your land and you give them
hospitality.
That is to say in one third of the tax revenue that you're collecting for the
empire or maybe one third of just your regular old private revenues.
This is a kind of accommodation.
Then it hits a commendation that costs money,
but it is part of a set of ways that the Roman elite figures out how to deal
with these
invaders,
collaborate with them.
So the Roman aristocratic land owners and the barbarian war leaders come to
various kinds of accommodation.
Now the accommodation differs depending on where we're speaking of.
And now we come to the point of having to describe
the barbarian kingdoms.
I've given you two maps,
one of which are you're not to show people who are not in the class.
This one,
the one with the arrows,
a Yale University is home to one of the great historians of our time.
Uh,
Walter Golfer.
And I can't believe that I'm talking about all sorts of people like Wickham and
got offered in something that's going to be a widely available.
But anyway,
let me express my admiration to him is one of the great,
uh,
early medieval historians.
It could certainly run rings around me.
Uh,
he's retired,
he taught at the University of Toronto.
And among his many works is one that completely destroys the notion of having
invaders with arrows.
This whole idea of,
you know,
who,
like,
they've got this path,
we know where they are.
They come from somewhere,
a SIOP where,
what,
what is now southern Sweden.
Scandia a lot of these histories or what purport to be histories,
say they came from Scandia and you can still read in not very old textbooks.
Oh,
uh,
you know,
the Visigoths came from Scandia and then they went here and then they went there
and they,
they're migrating all around and you have little arrows that show their
progress.
You're not supposed to do that.
I,
I'm not sure what you're supposed to do though,
as a substitute and had,
there's always with historically misleading things,
once you get rid of the misleading thing,
uh,
you're kind of helpless.
Uh,
if you're trying to teach this.
So I'm asking you to look at this really closely and not take it seriously and
asking you to memorize everywhere they went.
Uh,
but not to tell anybody.
Once they enter the empire,
then those arrows start to make sense.
I mean,
we know that the physical,
we're in the Balkans at the time of the Battle of Adrian Oakland three 78,
we know that they sacked Rome in four 10.
We know that they go down to Italy to try to get to the greeneries of North
Africa.
We know that they discover Omg,
I can't build a boat.
So then they come up,
uh,
the other side of Italy,
they settle in southern France.
They're kicked out of southern France by the Franks for the most part,
and they settle in Spain where the Arabs get them four weeks from now,
I think.
So the arrows are not completely deceptive,
and that's why,
uh,
I've,
I've given these to you and,
uh,
it's hard to tell which arrows applied to which tribes.
Uh,
so hence map tube
now too,
a lot calmer.
This is the situation in five oh six y five.
Oh six.
Because in that year,
the Franks whom we're going to be following a more closely the mirror Vingean,
Frank's,
defeat the Visigoths and start pushing them out of southern France.
So this is a map,
I guess before that defeat,
you see the Visigoths in southern France and northeastern Spain with the Basques
kind of in between them.
So this is the situation in 500.
There is no more Roman empire of the West or there is a fictitious Roman empire
of the West.
All of these people to varying degrees,
well not all of them,
most of them acknowledge some kind of suzerainty of Constantinople.
You'll read about Clovis,
king of the Franks in the beginning of the sixth century who gets some sort of
gift from the emperor in Constantinople,
a letter of appointment,
some robes,
various trinkets.
And uh,
according to Gregory of tour,
the historian of Clovis,
the title of console,
and he is very pleased with this.
He,
dawn's these robes.
He scatters coins just like a newly appointed,
uh,
emperor.
But is he obeying the emperor and a status to the Emperor Anna status?
He has starts sending orders to him or have any kind of administration?
No,
this is really just symbolic,
but we will talk about the relationship between the eastern empire and the
barbarians because it's going to change in the sixth century as the eastern
empire fends off its opponents and becomes more concerned to take back as much
as possible of the last western empire
in the year 500.
The most impressive of these barbarians would have been the Ostrogoths because
they are occupying Italy,
which is the most Roman,
the most prosperous,
the most intact,
economically and culturally of the,
uh,
of the former Roman empire of the West.
The Ostrogoths had been in the,
if you look at the arrows,
they had been maybe in the Crimean area around the Black Sea that came into the
Balkans.
They tried to attack Constantinople in the,
uh,
late fifth century
and they were defeated and they were encouraged to move into Italy by the
Byzantine emperor to get rid of Odoacer.
That military leader who's takeover of Italy and 76 is conventionally understood
to be the end of the Roman Empire in the West.
Okay.
The Ostrogoths had an impressive ruler named Theodoric
and they ruled from Ravenna.
The old last Roman capital in northeastern Italy,
and the tomb of Theodoric can still be seen in Ravenna.
Very impressive monument.
Roman education survived in Italy.
It would reach its last flowering with two figures.
I mentioned one of them last time,
but we theose
and Casio Doris.
Okay.
These are two key figures in the of classical learning,
but we theose
not perhaps literally the last person in the west who knew Greek,
but certainly the last person who tried to make Greek knowledge known two people
who could only read in Latin.
He conceived the project of translating all of Plato and Aristotle into Latin.
He started by doing a kind of introductory textbook,
like a lot of great projects.
This one was not completed.
In fact,
this one barely got off the ground because he was accused by Theodoric of
conspiring with the Byzantine Empire,
the eastern Roman Empire to overthrow him.
He was imprisoned for a year in prison.
He wrote one of the most magnificent works of philosophy
of
why we are alive and why we die.
The consolation of philosophy
and then he was executed.
Can't see your doors.
Uh,
live to be nine days.
So one of the differences between these two figures of the last gasp of Roman
culture in Italy is Casio Dora says relative longevity,
they're both figures of the sixth century who easiest dies in the five thirty's
Casio doors much,
much later.
Casio Doris also conceives of a program of education,
but it is more oriented towards Latin learning.
And Casio doors in some way is the founder,
or at least the transmitter to us of the idea of the liberal arts.
Casio doors is a religious figure,
but we,
theist is a Christian and he wrote on Christian topics,
but the constellation of philosophy,
interestingly enough is a stoical work as very little explicitly about
Christianity.
Casio Doris on the other hand,
is the guy who invented the idea that monks should copy manuscripts,
that the preserve of culture,
the place where it seeks refuge and is protected in barbarian times should be
monasteries.
This seems so self evident to us because if there's one thing we know about
monasteries,
it's,
you know,
guys hunched over and writing stuff and the preservation of learning.
But in fact,
monasteries start out as just,
um,
uh,
anti intellectual institutions where you pray and you don't,
spend a lot of time reading,
let alone copying,
let alone thinking she's supposed to have visions.
You're supposed to be inspired.
You're supposed to fast and you know,
become ecstatic.
It's Kaseya,
Doris who conceives of this as a contemplative and learn it project
the liberal arts means here things that are not immediately practically useful,
but that help aluminate
the person seeking after knowledge.
And what kind of knowledge is a person seeking after in the sixth century,
a day
they're seeking after knowledge of God and knowledge of the divine.
Why not just read the Bible?
I'm sure many of you have read the Bible or read parts of it.
The Bible is not an immediately evident document in terms of its view of the
world is total,
but it's full of mysteries.
It's full of obscurities.
Um,
it's a strange work that requires knowledge.
And explication or to celebrate divine services,
for example,
requires a certain kind of knowledge to know when Easter is,
to know the phases of the moon,
to know what day it is.
I think these monks or just anybody out in the countryside can't just look at
their phone and see what time it is.
There's a need for some practical knowledge,
but that involves abstract concepts like the movements of the planets.
This is what the liberal arts are and this is what's being preserved in the
Ostrogoths kingdom,
but the fate of [inaudible] just shows you the sort of duality of the barbarian
patronage of culture.
On the one hand,
the Ostrogoths in Italy or as civilized as these groups get on the other hand,
of course,
but with this is executed.
On the third hand,
you didn't have to be a barbarian to execute people.
After all,
Seneca was forced to commit suicide by Nero.
So the fate of intellectuals in the Roman Empire is not necessarily so much
better than the fate of intellectuals in the barbarian kingdoms.
The thing about the intellectuals in the barbarian kingdoms is there,
very few of them.
Seneca is great,
man.
It's too bad that he died and we could've had more works.
But there were lots of other philosophers.
There were lots of other playwrights.
Yeah.
But we see us,
we can say,
but with this and Casio Doris maybe are the two smartest people in the sixth
century.
Okay.
Judging by what they had access to,
what they read,
how they wrote,
and that's scary,
right?
If you can say that Isidore of Seville is the smartest man of the seventh
century,
or bead an Alk,
when are the smartest men of the eighth century?
It's not just a compliment to them.
It's a right,
you know,
some,
if you're rated like the 18th best tennis player in the United States,
that's a tremendous,
but presumably there are 200 tennis players who are ranked and behind them
they're 10,000 very good tennis players.
Right?
But what if you were the number one tennis player in the country and there was
no number four,
no number four through 100 million
tennis would be an endangered game.
Uh,
it would mean a lot,
but supposing nobody followed tennis anymore.
Right?
I mean,
perhaps,
I don't know.
I don't know enough about Ah,
antiquated games,
but some medieval game,
you know,
that only five people know how to play.
I could be the fourth ranked,
but here we're not talking about,
you know,
sports important though.
They are,
we're talking about the fundamental aspects of knowledge.
Vrx the artwork is a great ruler,
but he had a problem that is typical of many of these barbarian groups.
He had to hold his minority together.
The thing that made Italy the most,
uh,
and the wealthiest,
the most important,
the biggest prize for the barbarians is it's Roman population.
It's Roman wealth preservation of its cities.
But that also meant that the Ostrogoths are a tiny proportion of the total
population.
He needs to hold them together,
but he also needs to mollify the Romans.
Okay.
So it's a dangerous place for barbarian rulers or to way sir had already been
overthrown.
It's too valuable to the eastern empire and indeed apps after Theodoric died in
five 35,
very shortly thereafter,
the Byzantine Empire,
the eastern Roman Empire would invade Italy and devastated in the course of
conquering it.
In a 20 years war.
Now,
if you look at the map again and turn to North Africa,
you'll see we've got the vandals and what's now to means Ya and eastern Algeria
and then Morris Kingdom and Roman empire.
Uh,
ignore Roman Empire.
I don't know what they're talking about.
Uh,
Morris Kingdoms.
what does that mean?
Uh,
uh,
we don't really know who these people are either.
They're not invaders.
Their desert peoples who have now taken over what was formerly the Roman Empire
and they're pressing the vandals.
The vandals were less accommodating than V Ostrogoths.
They,
um,
were more fiercely Arion.
Yeah,
they persecuted the elite of the Roman population,
including the Roman bishops.
What?
They were very effective rulers.
They had a navy,
they were able to plunder Rome several times in the fifth century.
Okay.
But they were beleaguered by these morrish groups.
In other words,
native peoples of the North African desert.
And so by five Oh six,
there has shrunk.
They were also a minority in what had been a very populous part of the Roman
empire.
And
they tended to fight among each other.
They had internet seeing feuds.
And so we're talking about things that are common to many of these barbarian
kingdoms,
disorganization,
internal fighting,
alien,
religious beliefs,
particularly area and heresy.
And once they've done the plundering inability really to start making the
economy work very effective,
the vandals would be driven out of North Africa or,
or obliterated actually by the eastern Roman Empire in the five,
late five twenties,
early five 30.
Okay.
Now,
I'm not going to go through every one of these,
but I want to give you some examples of accommodation.
Uh,
go up to the British isles.
You'll see it says British kingdoms.
That means Celtic Kingdoms.
Oh,
who's remanence would later be Wales,
Scotland,
and then the Anglo Saxon Kingdoms.
The Anglo Saxons are invaders who come from the continent beginning in the for
four days.
This is the first place that Rome abandoned.
Here.
It looks more like a conventional invasion.
The invaders come and the Romans pull back their troops because they're afraid,
uh,
that gall is going to fall next.
Yeah.
And this is an island where the Roman impressed the Roman impact was less.
There isn't a large Roman majority and a small German minority.
Uh,
there is a Celtic majority that blends with the invaders or that seeks refuge in
these independent British kingdoms as they're called on the map to the west.
We don't know very much about what's going on in Britain at this time because
more than vandal north Africa more than Austria,
Gothic Italy,
uh,
the,
the past is obliterated.
There's very little Latin being written.
We have very little knowledge of what is going on.
So this is at one extreme of what might be called a Barbara [inaudible] versus
Rome Roman,
uh,
permanence.
Okay.
We're going to be talking about the Franks later
and we're going to talk a little bit about the Burgundians in closing today.
But this leaves really among the important groups,
the Visigoths,
the people who in a way started this with their invasions of the Balkans in the
late fourth century,
in five Oh six,
they control much of France,
the south and the West particularly and are trickling into Spain.
We will be following in a reading Gregory of tour,
the tremendous success of the,
um,
Frank's against the Visigoths.
And so the Visigoths will be pushed out.
What about the Burgundians?
You've read the Burgundian Code,
anything strike you about him,
Spencer?
Very status oriented.
Hair pulling.
Uh,
yeah.
Why?
What's that all about?
Yeah.
Um,
uh,
working with,
talked about how long hair or we have working status.
Yes.
So the,
uh,
the question was what does that salt,
this hair pulling?
It's a status symbol.
Uh,
we'll see that the mirror of engine kames wear long hair,
specially long hair.
And when they're finally deposed by the Carolingian,
that hair is cut.
Now of course,
all their hair is cut.
They're put in monasteries and monks are what's called Tan shirt.
You know,
they have,
uh,
if they're not completely bald,
they at least are pretty near.
Uh,
like many barbarian,
so-called barbarian people or like many people,
period.
There's certain signs of prestige symbols.
The Burgundian code is drawn up between four 83 and five 32.
It's drawn up in different stages.
The Burgundians,
we're a closer to the Ostrogoths in degree of Roman [inaudible].
There are a group that wants to be Roman or at least accepted by the Romans.
They write their own law code in Latin,
like the Visigoths for example.
Okay.
They also write a for of law code for the Roman population.
This law code is aware of disputes between Romans and Burgundians.
And if each has a different kind of law,
then how do you settle a problem that arises between members of,
uh,
both communities.
The Burgundian law in itself shows a lot of Roman influence,
uh,
for example,
in,
uh,
um,
chapter 18 you've seen this title of things that happened by chance and
probably,
you know,
it didn't seem very,
uh,
dramatic if any animal by chance or any dog by bite causes death to a man.
We ordered that among Burgundians,
the ancient rule of blame be removed,
hence forth.
This is an interesting question.
If my dog bites you and you die,
am I responsible?
Is your brother going to have to kill me?
That's what the Burgundian tradition would have been.
But here they say if it's an accident,
uh,
then I,
you can't,
your brother can't kill me.
This is the difference between,
um,
uh,
I mean this is a,
this is a tricky problem.
Those of you who,
uh,
have the good fortune to go to law school or going to study this first year
right towards a tort is so called civil wrong as opposed to a crime.
A crime is where I kill you cause I want to a tort is I leave a roller skate out
in the side on the sidewalk,
you trip and die.
I'm not going to be considered in the same league as someone who poisoned you,
but that rollerskates shouldn't be there.
Of course,
this is a crucial thing.
For example,
I've learned,
fortunately not from experience,
but from neighbors,
uh,
after hurricane Irene,
that if a tree in my yard falls on your house,
uh,
I'm not to blame.
Your insurance is going to have to cover that.
I'm really sorry about that tree.
But if you warned me,
I don't like the look of that tree in your yard.
It's leaning over like this and I'm afraid in the next storm it's going to fall
on your house and I don't do anything.
Then my understanding is that I'm liable for negligence.
This was a present and obvious nuisance.
It was an obvious threat and my neighbor called my attention to it and I didn't
do anything.
So next time it storms and your,
your house is threatened by somebody else's tree.
Uh,
you know,
just as the wind starts to blow go next door and say,
I don't like the look of that tree on your property.
You better do something.
But this is the,
these are real legal questions and they are handled in here with some
sophistication.
On the other hand,
there is vengeance,
right?
It's okay to practice vengeance.
Yeah,
but there are some limitations.
For example,
if I kill you,
your relatives can kill me,
but the can't just kill my cousin.
This is sort of individual directed and not clam directed venture.
There is a lot of talk about compensation and Vera gelled a four victims,
right?
How much you pay,
whether you grab them by the hair,
whether you cut off which finger,
whether they were free or slave,
whether they,
you know,
were skilled,
artisan or a surf.
I love a title 10
if anyone kills a slave barbarian by birth,
a trained house servant or messenger,
let them come pound 60 soliday
but 200 soliday.
If the slave is a skilled goldsmith,
40 solidly for a carpenter and so forth.
If you cut off someone's arm,
it's half of their very gout.
Very guilt is like murder their murder value.
So I have a murder value of a hundred solid cut off an arm.
You've got to pay me 50 solid.
This seems pretty crude,
doesn't it?
How does it strike you?
Yes.
I mean,
yeah,
but I think it gives a solution cause like a total outbreak.
It,
it is a maintenance of peace.
And um,
oh,
what about victims compensation
in the western legal tradition?
If you injure me,
it's a crime against the peace and the state punishes.
The perpetrator only relatively recently has this notions of victim's rights.
Victim's compensation,
uh,
have been entered,
which is like a reversion back to the notion that the crime really injures not
the state or the king or the piece that we all take for granted.
Uh,
but the individual who was affected,
but what makes it seem crude is the specificity of the offenses,
right?
If you look at the Connecticut
Criminal Code,
it's not quite so precise about hair pulling.
If anyone sees is a Freeman by the hair,
the fine is greater.
If he seized with two hands,
then one
maybe that has to do with intent.
One hair.
My one on one arm might be instinct I pulling your hair,
but two hands argues of serious intent to do harm or it's more humiliating.
This is a culture in which there's an awful lot of shame and compensation for
public shaming.
Okay?
A lot of a questions of personal status and title for about thefts.
If a slave commits a theft,
he's either beaten or killed and of story Freeman.
That is to say people who are not slaves pay fines and compensation.
Okay.
It's a violent society.
Of course,
all criminal codes show various forms of violence.
There's a lot of mutilation.
There are a lot of assaults on women
compensation for the assaults on free.
Women are paid to the women themselves,
but in native Freeman who assaults a maid servant must play,
must pay.
The master maid servant as a slave is regarded as a commodity.
And then finally,
it's a society in which at least according to the official law code,
men are more valued than women,
or men are less regulated than women.
If a man breaks a marriage in title 34,
he's fine.
If he goes and runs off with another woman,
if a woman goes off and runs off with another man,
she used to be smothered to death.
On that enlightened note,
we'll leave the Burgundian code.
Uh,
and indeed we're going to leave the barbarians only for a little while.
Next week we're going to talk about the eastern Roman Empire and why it survived
and even why a flourish.